to lose what was a distinction what was
a difference at 1am this morning verses
24 hours ago well 24 hours ago one am
the streets were mostly clear 1 a.m.
this morning there were some defiant
protesters who were walking up to where
the police were stationed in challenging
the police haunting the police and after
all of that the police responded with a
pretty strong force a lot of teargas it
looked like a war zone there was smoke
in the air tear gas all over the plate
and it was a very very disastrous
picture toulouse it's important that you
are there to weigh and judge what I'm
seeing out on social media and frankly
within the mainstream media which is the
size of the press contingent versus the
size of the event obviously these are
important events involving the president
and the Attorney General way the size of
the protest and the violence versus the
reporting of it when you're on the
street well there are dozens and dozens
of reporters without more than a hundred
on the scene but there are also a large
number of protesters during the peaceful
part of the protest when the protest
became a little bit more violent and
these cops came out with a little bit
more force a lot of the peaceful
protesters left and the reporter stayed
behind so it is it remained just a few
defiant protesters and a large number of
reporters and that's why you have sort
of that large reporter contingent it
looks like it maybe and maybe even
larger than they protesters that a
roommate good perspective there to lose
some the protesters have been calling
for authorities to make an arrest in the
shooting death of Michael Brown any
update on that front right now there's
still no charges being being filed as
the local prosecutor is looking over all
of the details the federal government is
also on on ground with about 40
investigators interviewing people and
general attorney general holder will be
here tomorrow so there is a progress but
no occurrences yet so loose last night
was the first night
for that the police decided to to lift
the curfew can you explain why they did
that well they also called in the
National Guard so they felt that they
had the Vista strategy to make this a
peaceful protest and not force people to
go home the curfew really led to some
confrontation after midnight with cops
using tear gas to disperse people to
enforce enforce the curfew they took
that away but it still ended up with the
same result of teargas and and violent
confrontations between police and
protesters